fueron 56 votos a favor de la
constitucionalidad de segundo proceso
político juicio político contra el
presidente en eeuu y 44 en contra de la
constitucionalidad le doy los seis
nombres de los republicanos susan
collins de maine bill cassidy de
luisiana lisa murkowski de alaska mitt
romney como se esperaba de yuta venes al
de nebraska y pat tomei de pensilvania
este es uno nuevo que muchos no
consideraban en la lista de republicanos
que apoyaron el segundo juicio político
llama la atención que me eché mccann
droid que tanto criticó a donó trompa
por haber auspiciado por haber incitado
a esta estos simpatizantes que se
tomaron el capitolio el 6 de enero haya
votado en contra de la
constitucionalidad de este segundo
juicio político
cristóbal como lo fue entonces a la
defensa de donald trump porque están
siendo criticados que dijeron ellos hoy
a lo largo de la jornada mientras el
senado debatida
si eran nueve fiscales que son
representantes a la cámara demócratas
que fueron seleccionados por la
presidenta de la cámara representantes
para que en el senado representarán al
partido demócrata en el proceso de
impeachment en versus estos dos abogados
que contrató donald trump hace una
semana los dos abogados son bruce castro
y david show en muy criticado fue bruce
caster y se les critica sobre todo pues
la falta de precisión en las citas la
falta de conocimiento de la minucia de
la ley sobre todo en lo que tiene que
ver con la enmienda 14 que dice que pues
una presidente de cualquier funcionario
público en funciones no puede estar
relacionado o haber apoyado algún acto
de insurrección pues cuando dio la cita
y cuando citó a otros medios de
comunicación lo hizo de forma imprecisa
además se presentó con una libreta
amarilla como de apuntes como no
tomándola con mucha seriedad
a una fecha y un momento tan importante
para eeuu y para la defensa de donald
trump y se critica también a david owen
de haber sido bastante pasional bastante
activista parecía un simpatizante más de
donald trump con su tono bastante
ferviente apoyando al expresidente
donald trump de hecho island
darle al en el abogado anterior del ex
presidente de donald trump el primer
juicio alan del court si dijo dijo que
pues no entendía muy bien que estaba
haciendo la defensa de donald trump en
esta ocasión dijo que no lo estaba
haciendo muy bien lo dijo a newsmax a un
medio republicano así que si esto se
compara además el buen la buena
presentación con pruebas y con vídeos
que hicieron los demócratas pues así en
contraste bastante bastante importante
cristóbal que sigue entonces en la
agenda para esta semana hasta que un
primer paso en este juicio político
claro a partir de mañana al mediodía
empiezan ya los argumentos formales
entonces los demócratas liderados por
estos nueve representantes a la cámara
específicamente por jamie rating pues
tendrán 16 horas para presentar los
argumentos de por qué el presidente el
ex presidente de donald trump pues debe
ser padre debe debe ser juzgado en este
juicio político y tendrán 16 horas
también la defensa de donald trump los
dos abogados que le acabo de mencionar
estas 16 horas claras eran expansys
serán usadas en dos días diferentes
después vendrán las preguntas de los
senadores y después vendrá entonces la
el tiempo en la que se cita o no a los
testigos para después tener la votación
final gracias cristóbal por este reporte
desde la ciudad de washington